the largest restaurant chain is getting
a makeover
subway grew from one Connecticut
storefront to nearly 45,000 locations in
more than 100 countries that's bigger
than McDonald's but the company shrank
for the first time in 2016 and now it
hopes a new look will help jumpstart the
50 year old brand in a story you'll see
only on CBS this morning we went behind
the counter the subway CEO and lifelong
employee Suzanne Greco she talked in her
first TV interview about taking over the
company started by her big brother and
the struggles of staying competitive in
the fast food industry today the subway
experience is familiar around the world
but when 17-year old Fred De Luca opened
Pete's super submarines in 1965 it was a
family affair we came from a very modest
family and the idea to open that first
sandwich strip shop was really for Fred
my brother to generate money to pay for
his college because we didn't have any
money you were in a subway store at age
7 right I was so intrigued with this
idea that we owned a business i this was
like a big deal to me and I just wanted
to be a part of it in 1974 De Luca began
recruiting outside owners to buy Subway
franchises by 1990 there were 5,000 but
Subway's founding family received
devastating news in 2013 De Luca had
leukemia and he named his little sister
Suzanne Greco as his successor those who
worked for their family will attest to
the fact that their hardest on you never
did he want people to think that he
handed something to me or that I didn't
earn it and you know when we got toward
the end of this you know he said you're
ready I want you to carry on the legacy
I was stunned to learn that subway has
almost 45,000 and McDonald's only has
like 35,000 you're bigger than
McDonald's yes we are the largest
restaurant chain out there but it really
comes down to one Samuel
that one sandwich that one customer and
serving you know seven and a half
million sandwiches a day how many
sandwiches a day seven point five
million sandwiches are served in the
subway daily hi I'm Jared the subway guy
Greco took control in the midst of a
public relations crisis national
spokesman Jared Fogle was arrested on
child pornography charges
the following year rivals grew while
Subway sales declined and for the first
time the company closed more locations
in the US than it opened what do you
think caused that decline in sales well
there's a lot of disruption so we were
the ones that started with this fresh
revolution that's how we started and
that's who we're going to be that's who
we are but many brands are starting to
do that and that is what customers want
so where was subway failing to innovate
consumers ideas about food and their
ideas about restaurants and service have
evolved and being the size that we are
it's not as simple to make a change but
we are making rapid changes those
changes include renovated storefronts
highlighting Subway's use of fresh
produce kiosks where customers can place
orders and a mobile app where loyalty is
rewarded do you feel like you have to
reinvent subway for the 21st century
fresh nutritious customized food at an
affordable price was relevant 50 years
ago that is still relevant today but we
do have to evolve because fresh has a
different meaning than it had 20 years
ago Greco pointed his Subway's
partnership with farms across the
country that allow it to move produce
from field to sandwich in a matter of
days this is where all the magic really
happens still she says the key to subway
success resides behind the counter this
may be the first time a CEO has ever
made me a sandwich I love it I love
making sandwiches it taught me so much
facing a rapidly changing industry Greco
believes that fulfilling her brother's
goal of one
hundred thousand locations remains
within reach the idea of being able to
provide this fresh nutritious customized
sandwich and an affordable price I feel
that yes every community should have
that available to them
thank you we were taking a look at sort
of the top ten restaurant chains in
America you're the only one who has a
female as the CEO is that give you a
certain certain amount of pride oh I'm
extremely proud to be leading this brand
it's really really exciting for me and I
don't think that there's anybody out
there that knows more about this brand
or loves this brand more than I do and
they're expanding overseas they're gonna
redesign all these stores and remodel
them but it's interesting and it's a
great American story yeah she had a big
smile when you said you're the only
woman I like that and we should point
out they make their own bread they get
me when they say fresh-baked bread made
here well that smell I know I asked her
what's the secret ingredient that smell
you can smell I mean her graduate school
was flooded working with him yeah
knowing that she was going to take over
yeah yeah and Charlie likes subway I
just learned
everybody likes subway you're watching
CBS congratulations you Suzanne Greco
you go well in the bad ass category
you're watching CBS this morning